yeah so
again thank you for the invitation to
speak here
um this is not really a talk about
quantum hamiltonian complexity but when
umesh
gave me a call a few weeks ago and asked
if i could give a talk he just said you
know he suggested it should be fun and i
guess it'll be at the end of the day um
so hopefully this will just be
uh it'll be interesting for all of you
and will be another perspective on how
work in quantum information and even
quantum complexity can potentially
inform uh questions in physics and so
i'm going to be talking about space-time
quantum cloning and black holes and so
it's going to be talk about
impossibility
uh and possibility particularly with
respect to quantum cloning
and it's going to be really more
specifically about surprising
possibilities uh and in principle
impossibilities and what we can conclude
from
in principle possibilities in
possibilities and how far in principle
in principle needs to be to draw
interesting conclusions for physics
all right so we'll start off with
something we can all agree on
that is the no cloning theorem
we all know that there is no physical
process that given an unknown quantum
state phi
can produce two systems in the same
quantum state phi
that should work for for all possible uh
states five uh another way of saying
that is just that quantum information
cannot be replicated in space
that's a
i guess an uncontroversial point um
and this has great consequences from the
point of view of quantum information
theory in particular it means that
measuring an unknown quantum state has
to cause disturbance because if you
uh could measure an unknown quantum
state without causing disturbance then
you just measure it and measure it
measure it until you knew what it was
and then you could make as many clones
as you wanted to uh and so from the
practical point of view this you know
this is what actually gives rise to
quantum key distribution and other
applications of quantum mechanics
of some potentially practical
applications of quantum mechanics
so we all agree on no cloning it's
bedrock you know it's fundamental you
cannot copy quantum information
and yet right and yet um
if we expand our point of view a little
bit and think not just about space but
about space and time and this is not
this is not a controversial thing to do
even though we don't necessarily think
too much in the in these terms and
quantum information
um
then we could think about for example
the state of a single spin and there's
the space time diagram representing the
trajectory of that spin the world line
and so it's moving around a little bit
and the quantum state of that spin phi
is carried along with the spin right uh
and so at each point in time that
quantum state uh you know is present on
that world line and so while we couldn't
copy quantum information in space
we without much difficulty can copy it
in time
right and in fact not only can we copy
it in time we have to copy it in time
that quantum mechanical evolution is
unitary uh and so there's no way to
destroy information from one time to the
next you know the quantum information
was at time t1 it's going to be at time
t2 as well um
and so
one of the purposes of this talk i'm
going to have kind of two aspects to it
is going to be to really precisely
characterize which forms of replication
are possible and if the story were just
this simple you know carrying quantum
states along trajectories then that
would not be an interesting story to
tell so i'll you know
i'll inform you right now that the range
of possibilities is really quite
surprising and quite interesting i think
it tells us something potentially deep
about the relationship between
information and space time
um
and i guess i've already said that all
right so first the the inadequacy of
trajectories you know we can see right
away the trajectories aren't good enough
uh and we can see that by looking at
some well-known
aspects of quantum information so here i
have a depiction of the teleportation
protocol and i imagine most of the
people all the people in the room know
about teleportation
uh hands up if you like teleportation
all right okay so we all agree all right
so the important thing about
teleportation uh is that in some sense
the quantum information phi is split
into two pieces right it's somehow
carried both along the entanglement but
it can't be entirely carried along the
entanglement because that would violate
causality it's also carried along the
classical data uh that is the the
outcome the bell measurement used to
perform the teleportation and so
the information is not carried along a
single trajectory i mean some people
talk fancifully about the information
traveling backwards in time and then
forwards in time but that i don't know
if that makes sense i mean what's really
going on here is that just
uh tracking the information through a
single trajectory just doesn't tell the
full story
um we could also talk about systems that
are actually encountered in physics like
systems that have topological order uh
and in these systems that have
degenerate ground states um
the
it's impossible to access the
information by only looking at some
localized collection of degrees of
freedom that you actually have to
perform uh measurements of
degrees of free or perform some kind of
measurement that spans a significant
fraction of the whole system and in
practice what that means is that the
quantum information is replicated in
multiple overlapping subsets of the
sample
right and so again a trajectory is just
a completely inadequate way of talking
about the location of the quantum
information here we have overlapping
delocalized quantum information
all right so why would we want to
consider this question or why do we want
to actually inject space-time back into
quantum information um i mean one reason
and this is the
kind of actually lurking in the
background is the motivation for the
work that i did i'm talking right now
about some work with alex may a student
at mcgill university um
is this this old sordid story of bit
commitment so after the discovery of
quantum cryptography uh there was a lot
of excitement about the cryptographic
possibilities for quantum information
and a natural thing to try was this
this primitive called bit commitment um
and i'm not going to describe in detail
what it is but the basic story is that
it's a very powerful cryptographic
primitive from which you could build uh
very useful uh
well
you could you could perform useful tasks
like secure two-party quantum uh
two-party computation
and so way back now 20 years ago in 1993
uh in the
you know very reputable fox conference
there was a paper telling us that uh you
could prove it yet provably secure
quantum bit commitment uh from or a big
commitment from quantum mechanics um
and the the authors were no slouches
they include three of the inventors of
teleportation um
but then uh
what four years later in another
reputable journal uh one of the students
of uh jim blassau you know dared to uh
contradict his his platform uh and uh
and tells us that
quantum bit commitment is actually
impossible you can't use quantum
mechanics um and yet you know then a
couple years later again physical review
letters
the commitment is possible so what's
going on you know what actually changed
and the point is that to actually get
big commitment to work um you could you
could use a physical assumption but the
physical assumption was not uh
the underlying physics was quantum
mechanicals then you use the causal
structure of special relativity and so
the basic moral there is that if you're
interested in the physics of information
and the applications that you really
should take into account not just
quantum mechanics but also
space time
so another motivation and i'm just going
to go quickly into this right now
because the second half of my talk is
going to be about this business of
cloning and firewalls and and so on but
i just wanted to give you the flavor uh
of what it is
um it has to do with the problem of
black hole evaporation
so
that your last comment sort of allowed
for the fact the possibility that the
the last two things were consistent
so were the last two things these papers
were consistent that they were both oh
no they're entirely consistent i mean
the titles are inconsistent but the
assumption yeah once you look at the
assumptions you realize that uh is that
true of the original thing too
no the original thing was just wrong
but the original thing uh modified or
examined a class of attacks on the
crypto system um but they
they didn't quite understand um
the full range of possibilities and so
they proved that for
what they thought were a full set of uh
complete set of attacks that were just
not universal the protocol was secure
okay so now we're going to be interested
totally shifting gears but this is again
motivation uh for why we would study uh
questions about cloning and propagation
of information in space time
um
and
here we have uh this is going to be a
space or
uh my some of my favorite coordinates
for a short shield black hole um
and so
here we have uh let's see this is this
is a supposed to represent a short show
black hole in going light rays propagate
parallel to the u axis outgoing light
rays propagate parallel to the v axis
and there's a sphere at each point right
because i've had to suppress two
dimensions here
and i like this this choice of
coordinates because it shows you very
quickly
where the interior of the black hole is
inside this v here
any any signal has to travel within the
45 degree uh sort of forward light cone
and it's going to hit the singularity so
here's the interior the black hole
here's the exterior of the black hole
uh
and just to i guess the background
everyone here i imagine knows this um
the black holes are not so black back in
the 1970s uh stephen hawking taught us
that black holes should be actually
radiating and so they'll evaporate and
over time they'll disappear and in his
calculation he found that
there was no room uh for the uh
for the evaporation products to actually
contain any information about how the
black hole was formed and so this seemed
to be a process that would convert a
pure state into a mixed state and then
and therefore violate the unitary of
quantum mechanics um and so that was a
big puzzle in physics for a long time
uh
until i guess the
late 90s um
and the ads cft correspondence i think
there are maybe some experts in the back
uh convinced most physicists that
ultimately the black hole evaporation
was unitary but it didn't solve all the
puzzles so that's the that's the
background for this uh this story uh i
want to think about what happens even if
you know even if black hole evaporation
is unitary so unitary is saved can we
make sense of what's happening in the
process
uh
and the kinds of thought experiments
that were first proposed back in the
early 90s for thinking about
or
not the first thought experiments but
some of the thought experiments for
thinking about the self-consistency of
unitary black hole evaporation actually
involved cloning and so the kind of
question that people asked were just
okay we have an alice at side she has
some quantum system in state phi
and she allows it to fall into the black
hole
and these are going to be very very
large black holes and so
uh
if this uh
yeah uh by the equivalence principle uh
if if you're freely falling uh well if
you're freely falling then you shouldn't
actually perceive anything special near
the horizon uh that the kinds of things
that are actually going to disturb you
are title forces right so the force on
your feet and on your head are different
but for a very large black hole you can
actually make uh the vicinity of the
horizon very homogeneous and so there
won't be significant tidal forces and so
as far as anyone can tell and in order
to be consistent with general relativity
what should happen is if you as you
cross the horizon of a black hole is
that the quantum information just ends
up inside so we have quantum information
inside
hawking told us
taught us that the uh that there will
also be radiation
and if that if ultimately the process
can be described unitarily then if you
collect enough radiation you should have
a copy of the quantum state outside the
black hole as well
um but this you know on its face looks
like a cloning machine right we actually
you know you can think about a space
like slice passing through the uh the in
falling phi and passing through almost
all of the hawking radiation and so
you'll have phi inside the black hole
fly outside the black hole and it looks
like you've actually cloned quantum
information and so this yeah this was
noticed back in the 19 early 1990s um
that in trying to preserve unitarity you
immediately ran into
a problem that unitary
a violation of unitarity
on the other hand um the the the
solution that was proposed way back when
way back then was that uh perhaps these
two copies of phi are not really
independent
right that uh there appear to be two
copies but you could ask the question is
there any experiment that will actually
ever confirm that there are two copies
uh certainly someone staying outside
collecting hawking radiation and never
going inside the black hole would never
see there was a second copy and so uh
the the story that you would tell is
that the actual hilbert space of quantum
gravity uh only contains one copy and
you actually have to perform some
transformation on your observables to
get from the point of view of somebody
falling in and someone's staying outside
um and so the kind of experiment that
you would propose to actually see if
this is self-consistent is you'd have a
bob stay outside the black hole uh
follow you know collect enough talking
radiation that he has a copy of phi
and then jump in to try to compare notes
with alice and as i've drawn things
right here alice and bob are going to
hit the singularity before they ever
ever have a chance to compare notes uh
so what you could imagine alice doing is
at some point you know on her trajectory
inwards turning around uh shooting the
quantum information uh on a an outgoing
radial light ray uh towards bob you can
see here she waited too long uh so that
the
uh the message doesn't actually get to
bob before he hits the singularity but
if she sends her message soon enough it
will hit bob and they'll be able to
compare notes but as you can see the
longer bob waits the less time alice has
to send her message and you can extract
it straight from there because the less
uh
the shorter the time interval in which
alice has to prepare her message the
higher frequencies she has to use the
more energy she has to use and if you
just impose a very you know crude
constraint like the energy she injects
into that wave packet is less than a
constant fraction of the mass of the
whole black hole uh then you can
actually find a sort of limit on how
long bob can stay outside and still
actually perform the experiment uh and
what they found is that uh back in the
1990s if you study young black holes uh
there's no chance of actually performing
this experiment that for a solar mass
black hole bob would have to stay
outside on the order of 10 to the 67
years
whereas the amount of time that he would
actually have to be if he wanted to
perform the experiment he'd only have
about one second inside the black hole
before he had to jump in so one second
10 to the 67 years no big deal absurdly
safe
i looked at this
in a modified version with john prescott
in 2007 uh where we studied old black
holes and i won't get into the details
um
because i'm gonna talk about other stuff
uh related but the entanglement
structure is different uh and so um the
game is actually much tighter but it you
we still found that it's safe uh that uh
there's no way to perform this
experiment
but just in 2012 uh almeri uh
merolf uh polcinsky
came up with a new thought experiment
that evades all of the you know all of
the the fancy stories that we were able
to tell that eliminated the
contradictions um and these are these
black hole firewalls that i'll get into
all of that was by way of motivation but
the point being that what's going on
here is that we're getting confused by
thinking about cloning in space time
right that's really the the issue uh
that's uh uh that's at the core of all
of this but we're thinking about cloning
in a situation where we don't even trust
the structure of space-time i i write
down some kind of diagram like this and
uh and i know that if the black hole of
operation is unitary that uh that the
causal structure is different than what
i've just drawn for you and so we're
trying to draw conclusions about you
know the self-consistency of cloning and
what can be done and what cannot be done
in a situation where it's really unclear
that what we're saying makes any sense
and so the motivation uh one of the
motivations for the beginning of this
talk is going to be that before we can
even really aspire to analyze this we
should understand what happens in good
old minkowski space
and in minkowski space there's actually
much more to uh to discover than you
might have thought
well so i mean
the the details of the coordinates
really don't matter uh
that um
that in this show in this choice of
coordinates um
again uh
the future of a point is always actually
the 45 degree forward light cone right
the singularity exists on this hyperbola
up above and so if you're inside the v
that's that actually that corresponds to
the interior of the black hole and
everything uh outside here
uh corresponds to the exterior of the
black hole
the inside of the black v
yeah the black hole yes has some
internal structure that's a singularity
being drawn
i've drawn it in this extended way
but um
that's
it's a point um but it's i mean this is
just uh it's just you can think of a
depiction
that all of these points are identified
uh
like you should just you should just
interpret this as as drawing the causal
structure um
but uh
yeah
in these coordinates how do i interpret
alice jumping into the black hole
turning around firing her flashlight
back at bob was just behind right you
describe that yeah so what's going on
right there here's alice falling in she
starts out outside the black hole
she travels inwards i've actually shown
it uh i've chosen it so it's not quite
45 degrees so this is a time-like
trajectory
uh and after she crosses the horizon
uh she turns around and sends out a
radial pulse
in the outgoing direction which is right
here
and it makes contact with in-falling bob
right before they they touch the
singularity there
does that make uh
yeah um
yeah
uh so it sounds like you gave a physical
argument for why you know this cloney
issue isn't an issue but uh that doesn't
seem to get rid of the mathematical
issue that
um you know yeah no i mean ultimately
you want a theory right uh but that the
the kind of picture that uh susquehanna
relation at oakland where we're
proposing um at the time at least was
that uh you should describe the physics
from the point of view uh of an observer
right and that if you tried to describe
the physics from some kind of god's eye
view that covered the entire space time
uh that you might actually sort of be uh
inserting more in there than really you
know than you can properly describe uh
and so there'd be some description of
the physics from the point of view of
the in-falling alice observer another
description from the of the physics from
the point of view and observe who stays
outside and never jumps in uh and there
would be some transformation some
unitary transformation of the hilbert
space that relates uh these these two uh
you know these two descriptions and so
um
the observables uh that measure phi in
the interior would get mapped to
observables that measure phi in the you
know for for the in-falling alice would
get mapped to observables that measure
phi in some complicated way in the
radiation for bob i mean it's not
uh it's not articulated very you know
it's it's sort of a pipe dream to
actually be able to construct that
transformation but that's how uh that's
how it
it's supposed to work
physics
do you still describe
hole evaporation as a unitary or is it
just some
unitary from the point of view of an
observer who stays outside
yeah
because from that from the point of view
of that observer you start off say with
no black hole this matter collapses to a
black hole it ultimately evaporates away
uh and then you ask what is the
transformation that uh relates the you
know the in states to the out states and
that should be a unitary transformation
yeah so this sort of problem like this
happens when you have this similarity
uh black holes but
why i mean is everything safe if you
only have a character spacetime but not
necessarily flat well
if you have this picture of tensor
product
your reverse space can be decomposed as
the tensor product of uh universes of
different regions or
what really seems to be confusing uh
causing the problem here is not well the
singularity is clearly an issue uh but
what's really already creating the
problem is the horizon
right it's like it's the
it's the existence of this horizon which
is actually a physio it has some uh
which is shielding information inside
this region uh of space-time um
so i'd say that the c the singularity
almost almost certainly has something to
do with it but what what is already
causing the issue here is the horizon
um
can you ask my question horizontally i
have space yeah or yes
okay vertically entirely my usual light
color i have a picture okay i think of a
black hole living somewhere in my galaxy
style being three dimensions this is the
one but one space dimension so it should
be at some point on the line
but instead you've drawn it sort of
living off in my future light code and i
can't reconcile these pictures
um
ah so there is a
there's a sphere at every point right so
if you if you slice this and then as you
know i say this is the horizon the
horizon here is a sphere
right so that the black hole uh is
sitting you know the the horizon of that
black hole is sitting uh and it's some
spherical region in space time
um and in in these yeah
this is
uh
this is a spherically symmetric
spacetime there's one uh there's one
black hole and it's at the center um
in your picture the black hole expanding
with light speed now
um well that's just the choice of
coordinates
i mean it's just getting
larger and larger so i don't
understand your choice
but
maybe only okay i mean it's a cute
picture anyway okay i mean maybe we can
take that offline a little bit and
discuss it but uh i really want just to
pick the causal structure like it would
for for our purposes i i didn't even
need to draw this and could have just
drawn a picture that uh that had the
causal structure
um
but i do want to get into the you know
the actual results here um so what i'm
going to try to do in whatever time
remains i'm going to tell you about uh
all of the different ways that quantum
information can be replicated in
minkowski space um and actually it
extends beyond that i don't think
there's uh as long as we don't have
horizons complicating the issue uh curb
space is not is not a problem and we'll
give a complete characterization and
then in some time that remains hopefully
i'll have a chance to tell you about uh
some of the proposals for
wiggling out of these uh
of this firewall problem i'll tell you
what the firewall problem is and see
whether we can gather some comfort from
computational complexity or i guess some
solace from post-selected quantum
mechanics both of which i think are kind
of radical ideas and quite possibly
wrong but yeah that's that's okay
okay so first we have to make sense of
what we mean by replicating quantum
information in space time so here i have
uh two uh diamonds in space time so i'm
going to define a causal diamond if i
have two points a y and a z and z is in
the future of y then i can look at the
intersection of the future of y with the
past of zed okay uh and so that defines
a diamond here i have a d zero for the y
zero zero and a d one for y one z one um
oops
and we could ask the question uh
can d0 and d1 uh both contain the same
quantum information can i replicate
quantum information in those two
diamonds i guess maybe i'll ask you a
question is this a is this a possibility
uh
to replicate information and we know
that we can't replicate information
in space like regions you know the
information starts with there we can't
actually uh
replicate it but in this configuration
does it look like it's possible
or hands up if you think it's possible
okay and if you think it's impossible
and you're unsure okay well this is this
is very easily possible right all you
have to do if you you know some
information is originally localized at
some point s you know far in the past i
could just move it to this point p in
the corner of the diamond and then uh
again i'm uh i'm going to use the
convention throughout the talk that
light travels on 45 degree angles and so
i just you know send it from this corner
up into up into that diamond and so i'll
have the particle will be inside this
diamond and will also be inside that
diamond and so i will have replicated
the quantum information it will be in
two of these these diamonds there's no
there's no difficulty it's just the
trajectory case
and if we're only talking about two
diamonds that's actually all that can
happen uh that if the two dime you know
if it's possible to send a message from
some point in diamond you know one of
the diamonds to some point in another uh
then that gives me a procedure for
replicating the information i just you
know actually send the information on
the other hand if they're uh if the
diamonds are not causally related if
it's impossible to send a message from
one to the other then that means that
they're all the points are space like
separated and so replicating the
information would amount to cloning
uh and so
there we you know for two diamonds we've
actually analyzed the whole problem uh
and i should say that adrian kent is the
first guy who sort of point you know
nailed this down as an interesting
question to think about
because
to answer these questions you need both
quantum mechanics and relativity right
that
that if you don't include quantum
mechanics then you can copy information
any way you want if you don't include uh
relativity uh then there's no there's no
causality constraints so uh this
question actually intimately involves
both
now if you're not comfortable with the
idea of you know you're not sure what i
mean by replicating information in these
diamonds it's useful to actually just
think about the causal diamond geometry
a little bit uh so here i've drawn a
causal diamond
uh
and we can foliate it uh by space-like
surfaces right so i can take the
interior of this diamond and i can
say
at the uh
at the the belt i can draw a space like
surface and another space-like surface
above it uh and as you can see just from
the causal structure if i know the state
on this space like slice then i can
evolve it forward to the next slice
because there can be no influences
coming from outside that will affect
what happens right by construction uh an
event that happens out here can't affect
what happens on the next purple slice
and this basically means that the time
evolution from one slice to the next
inside this causal diamond is unitary
and so we can more or less assign a
single density operator to a causal
diamond and so what i mean by
replicating the information in the
causal dining is that if i take that
density operator assigned to the diamond
there's a fixed unitary transformation
that will actually extract the quantum
information uh just like what we would
normally mean by decoding quantum
information in some
some process
um
okay so that's uh
that's one fact so the information
so if phi is present on one of these
space-like slices uh it has to be
present on all of them and so rep you
know when i say replicating information
inside the diamond if you want you can
just say well what he means by that is
he's putting the information on one of
these space-like slices
uh and if you are inclined you could
you know a natural one to choose i have
a cone uh
or i have two cones intersecting and
they intersect in a sphere
and so this is actually the same thing
as saying i choose a time and i
shoot you know i place a sphere uh in
space at that given time and i've
localized the information inside that
sphere that's that's totally equivalent
of course there's no reason that i
should choose the spatial coordinate of
the the z to be the same as the spatial
coordinate as the y uh and so
um i could actually be talking about you
know i could think about an inertial
observer who floats uh through both of
the you know the the base point and the
apex uh and
what i actually mean then is localizing
the information to what appears to be a
sphere from the point of view of that
inertial observer but you know from the
point of view of this observer
it's going to be some
some ellipsoid
all right
so one last little bit of causal diamond
geometry you can see that as i move the
apex point closer and closer to the
boundary of the cone
the diamond gets thinner and thinner
right until if i actually put the
diamond on the boundary of the cone it
degenerates to a line segment
and in the examples that i'll show you
it'll actually look like this not
because this is the most interesting
case but just because these are the
easiest ones to draw
uh
but you shouldn't think that i'm never
going to be talking really about actual
line segments because you can you can't
pit you can't fit any quantum
information into a
uh into a point you'd violate the
holographic bound so just think of them
as very you know very narrow diamonds
right i've actually you can see like
uh i've just i've displaced uh the
purple and the black just a little bit
so there's some thickness in the middle
so i have a very narrow diamond
now to actually succeed in this task of
replicating information and covering all
the possibilities i i told you that it
was not going to be sufficient to talk
you know to think about trajectories and
the tool that we really need is quantum
error correcting codes and i guess ben
reichardt is going to be telling you
about quantum era correcting codes but
not till tomorrow
and so i'll just you know we only need
the most basic of basic facts about them
uh and so we should uh what i'll really
need to tell you about is just say how
we encode a spin 1 system into a spin 3
system so
one three-dimensional system into three
three-dimensional systems
uh
yeah
how do you quantify the amount of
information in the diamond
um okay uh
i mean what i so i would actually define
this operationally right that um
that i i would say that if we take the
the information is inside the diamond
if uh there exists a unitary
transformation uh independent of the
state that you know we're interested in
such that when you apply it to the
density operator the diamond is actually
going to produce the state tensored with
some junk
um and if i to quantify how much
information was in the diamond i have to
say information about what
right
uh
like in this case there would be say one
qubit or you know one mode's worth of
information or something but uh
that if we
that otherwise i i mean
you could start talking about
entanglement entropies or something and
that gives you some you know some
measure of information inside at least
you know on one of these space like in
these space-like regions um but for my
purposes i'm really interested about in
specific information
have shown that
for example if you're in regular space
uh and you have access only to some i
mean it's a special case of a causal
diamond
very large one but still the fact that
yeah acts only to half of the space-time
means that for example if i
proliferate the number of species so
that naively the amount of information
goes like the log of the number of
species
you can't actually distinguish between
arbitrarily many species you could
globally but but you can't do the
rendering it maxes out
so you could
because of the thermal noise that you
have in a restricted space-time region
particular space oh okay sure you can't
actually discriminate
yeah no that's actually a very good
point um
so
so i mean i guess i'll agree that
there's actually a question right that
uh
so my definition which is just asking
about the existence of this unitary
transformation uh doesn't say anything
about whether or not this is a procedure
that could be implemented um whether
because of unreal type you know uh
thermal noise or other obstacles but
what you'll see actually is what uh
the theorem that we're going to get to
is actually going to describe an
explicit procedure for replicating this
information and it's going to be clear
that this is something that can be done
in the laboratory
um so we won't you know for the
constructive part of the theorem where
we show that uh this can be done in
interesting cases um these are like
these will actually be things that can
be done uh and the no go theorem is just
the trivial fact that i was showing you
before that you can't clone uh and so i
don't think we have to worry about the
question in this case
okay so uh encoding a spin one into uh
into three ones um
you know
there's gonna be some you know
interesting evolution if you run it for
just the amount of the right amount of
time uh if you prepare the or if you're
given the first uh
the first system in the state five but
you don't know fine
you prepare the other two systems in
known zero states some particular fixed
state what's going to come out is a
state psi and it's going to have a very
interesting property
which is that the quantum information
phi can be recovered from any two out of
the three outputs output spins
right so what does that mean it means
exactly the kind of thing i was telling
you about or i was describing before
uh if i get say these two spins here
there's some fixed transformation
independent of the input state that i
can apply uh such that when i act on
these two spins i'm going to get back
the quantum state phi on the on say the
output spin
spin so there's a procedure uh whereby i
can correct for the loss of any one out
of the three uh of these uh
of these spins
and if you want to know what it looks
like it's this but ben reichardt is
going to tell you in more detail about
quantum era correction tomorrow
um and we'll just call this a two two
three threshold quantum error correcting
code right so with any two out of the
three shares into which we've encoded
our our spin we can recover the
information
so now here is the this is my favorite
example it's a
uh sort of a non-trivial configuration
where we can see kind of the interesting
uh
well the interesting things that can
happen
so i have three causal diamonds here uh
as you can see uh they're of this kind
of degenerate type where they're they're
essentially line segments and they the
aspect ratio in this diagram is not
quite right but you should think that
the y's are on the vertices of an
equilateral triangle
uh and the z's are on the midpoints of
the edges of that triangle but displaced
in time
and uh and it's displaced in time just
long enough for a light ray to get
halfway between uh
to get halfway along the uh an edge of
this triangle
so
the
the causal diamonds are
are line segments on a light ray and the
the red lines are also
light rays traveling in space time so
that's the configuration here
and the goal is going to be to replicate
quantum information uh in these three in
these three regions and we can't do the
stupid thing we were doing before where
we just move the spin around uh i mean
that's pretty obvious because you could
say well suppose we move the spin s
somewhere into the two diamond
well
there's no way to get from the two
diamond to the zero diamond right that
would you know that would require that
you travel backwards in time so then you
could say okay well if we can't get from
the two diamond to the zero diamond
let's put the spin in the zero diamond
but then there's no way to get to the
one diamond and vice versa right so the
way that the uh these diamonds are
arranged in this kind of cyclic
configuration
directly precludes you from actually
carrying the information around
but what you can do is you can encode
phi
into a 2 3 threshold quantum error
correcting code
okay
so now we're going to take the original
quantum information and distribute it
into three particles
such that any two out of the three are
sufficient to recover the information
and now we'll just send one particle to
each of the ys
and we'll allow it to travel along the
the red light rays like that
and you may you know you may not have
seen that or you may i guess you saw it
you may not have caught it uh in doing
so we have replicated the quantum
information in each one of those
diamonds so let's just break it down uh
at this time we have one particle say
like for the two diamond we have one
particle at z2
at the beginning time we had one
particle at y2 but they're not the same
particle
right so so the
the two diamond actually contains two
particles and having two particles is
sufficient to reconstruct
the the quantum state fire to decode the
quantum state five
um
and just you know in case you you don't
quite see what's going on there remember
i told you that these line segments are
slightly thickened uh and so one of
these line segments looks kind of like
this and the particle at y2
is going to be inside on this space like
slice the particle z2 is also going to
be inside the space like slice so both
particles are on a space like slice
inside the diamond and so there's some
unitary transformation that we can use
to recover the information
and so
uh
well i
i like this example because it sort of
it really illustrates how quantum era
correction is necessary to properly
understand how information in principle
can be replicated
um but moving on from there uh
you know we can think about more
complicated scenarios um so here again
i've drawn some configuration of causal
diamonds uh in space-time and
the way that you should interpret this
again these are these these diamonds
that that uh yeah
so should we understand replicating
information to mean that any one of the
the diamonds could get the information
at the cost of screwing it up for
everybody else yes
uh so it's it's present as a potential
uh but yeah if you certainly if you
actually
do something active and change the
description like there's some there's
some situation where particles are
floating around and doing things uh and
the information will be replicated but
if you then change uh that situation by
acting inside one of these these
diamonds with some different uh some
different dynamics then all bets are off
as to whether or not the information
will be replicated as right you can
think of the protocol here as
diamond y1z1 remake that it's promised
to send part of the other stage collects
what is given it and then has two out of
the three yeah
there was another question
that was basically that was it okay yeah
uh
yeah exactly so
uh it's there as potential yeah
okay so this is a more complicated
scenario uh and in this picture each of
these diamonds lies on the face of this
cube in space time again t is the time
is the vertical direction um
and
oops
well again we could ask the question is
it possible to replicate the information
in this kind of bizarre configuration
of regions of space time
and if i were faced with this i'd have
no idea how to go about trying to answer
the question
but well the one thing that i wouldn't
know how to do
is to check whether the obvious
conditions are satisfied right that i
could check to see whether
whether being able to replicate the
information would amount to a violation
of the no cloning theorem
right
and we already you know we already saw
that we could just think about regions
pairwise and if any pair of regions is
essentially space like separated
then succeeding would amount to cloning
right
so we can check that here but it turns
out that every pair of these regions uh
from
if we if i look at any pair there's
always a way to send a message from one
of them to the other at least in one
direction like from the zero diamond i
can send a message to the one diamond
from the one diamond i can send a
message to the two diamond and so forth
so the obvious constraints uh on
replicating information uh are not
violated in this example um and the
theorem you know which i think is you
know kind of cute um
is that
that's all you need to check
if you have some crazy configuration of
regions and space time described by
these causal diamonds and you want to
know can the same quantum information be
replicated in all of them uh then all
you do is you look at the trivial
constraint which is that pairwise you
you check to see if the no cloning
theorem is violated
and if the no cloning theorem is you
know if you don't see a problem then
there exists a way to actually replicate
the information through all of those
regions um
and so
well
i i like the simplicity of that
statement i think that there's a message
there
um and
well maybe sorry
about 15 minutes okay maybe it's worth
uh
for the fun of it you know going through
the argument because actually not a hard
argument um
and
just see how it works so the theorem is
going to be that each and every causal
diamond uh can contain the same quantum
information if and only if every pair is
causally related right so that's that's
what i was saying before as long as you
don't have the obvious violation of no
cloning
um
and we'll just uh we'll use the the
complicated picture that i showed you
before as the sort of the test case the
example
so our proof we start off with two
diamonds n equals two uh and we already
saw that in that case just moving the
state around along a trajectory is all
we need to you know all we need to
understand uh and so as long as you know
if we have two diamonds and they satisfy
the conditions of the theorem we're good
to go
so let's assume the existence of a
procedure uh for any set of n minus one
diamonds right so we'll do this
inductively um
so now i'm going to look at uh my
configuration of diamonds and there's
always a way to send a message uh
if i take any pair of diamonds from from
one uh one of those diamonds to the
other like from the zero diamond we saw
before i can message the one diamond so
i'm going to draw a graph of the causal
relationships
from the one two diamond i can send a
message to the zero diamond and i can
continue this and i'm going to get a
graph uh a directed graph in which there
are edges between all of the vertices
and some of those edges might be
bi-directional
like if two regions overlap the edges
will be bidirectional
now what we can do with this graph is we
can just think of the subgraphs we get
by deleting one
one vertex
right uh and so those are those
correspond to problems in which we've
removed one of the one of the causal
diamonds from our original problem
and so by the inductive hypothesis on
each of these sub problems we can
actually succeed
right
um
and so all we need to do is we're going
to take our original quantum state phi
and again encode it into one of these
threshold error correcting codes that
are it's now going to have n shares and
as long as i have n minus one out of the
n shares i'm going to be able to recover
the quantum information
uh
and then we're going to assign one share
to each of these sub problems
okay
so
uh
so what's going to happen let we can ask
the question all right is the quantum
information about phi replicated in the
diamond d1 uh
well uh the first share of this quantum
era correcting code uh is going to be
assigned here and that share is going to
successfully replicate uh
the quantum the
have the the share information
replicated in diamond d1
the second sub problem doesn't have a
diamond d1 so it's not going to succeed
but in uh sub problems three and four we
will succeed
so on three out of the four of these sub
problems uh we actually have uh the
shares in the uh in diamond d1 and so by
the property of the quantum error
correcting code we can actually recover
the quantum you know recover the quantum
information
uh so that's the whole story now the
only bad thing i guess this is a
complexity theory crowd is that pretty
obviously
i took my original quantum state phi i
encoded into n shares recursively those
n shares i encode into n minus one
shares and then so on and so the number
of qubits required is going to scale
like n factorial five n regions um
now
that's that's just terrible right if you
think of this as some kind of
communications network where i want to
broadcast information uh with just say
55 nodes in my in my network and i if i
tried to prepare my initial state on
somewhere on the surface of planet earth
uh i'd have so many qubits that this
would collapse to a black hole so that's
not terribly good
um but you can design new quantum error
correcting codes that are actually much
better so you can do this with n-squared
qubits but i won't get into that
and i think i'll skip this business
so the basic point that i wanted to make
is that we can actually uh
take the no cloning theorem uh and
reinterpret it you know sort of reinvent
it for the 21st century uh in the
context of space time and what we
actually find is this very beautiful if
and only if condition
that if we want to replicate quantum
information in regions of space and time
the only constraints are the really
trivial ones
and there's an amazing kind of variety
of possibilities about how you can just
you can replicate the information um
you can actually use similar ideas not
just to replicate information but also
to exclude information from regions and
what you get then is a kind of
space-time generalization of the theory
of quantum secret sharing in which you
can have dynamically changing coalitions
you could have moving participants and
so on um and so i think this is actually
potentially an interesting
uh not a starting point because there
are you know there's a lot of
interesting work done on
cryptography uh the interaction of
quantum information causality
constraints and uh well and cryptography
but uh this is perhaps a hopefully a
nice contribution to the the foundations
of that area um
but again i i don't quite know how to
articulate it but i think there's
something deep being said there as well
about uh
about the structure of space and time
okay so now
i think i should go back a little bit uh
in the in the few minutes that are
remaining then just tell you uh just
tell you briefly about this
this modern version of the black hole
cloning problem and why why it's uh why
it's vexing people
so in the modern version of this problem
we make the observation instead of
talking about quantum information being
dropped into the black hole
we just think of the black hole itself
uh and the evaporation process hawking
told us uh is essentially um
well takes place through pair creation
essentially where you have uh particles
um being created that are essentially
maximally entangled one of them escapes
you know this is the b part of it
escapes uh out to infinity where it can
be detected by a bulb the other particle
actually falls into the black hole and
it's very important uh that those two
particles be essentially maximally
entangled and that's actually how
hawking derived the radiation uh the
existence of this radiation in the first
place
that you you use the equivalence
principle and you say the in-falling
observer should not detect anything at
the horizon and you chain you know then
you perform the appropriate change of
coordinates to describe things in terms
of uh an observer who stays outside and
you see that the state which is vacuum
for the infalling observer is extremely
entangled uh when viewed from the point
of view of an observer outside uh and so
if you if you don't have the right
structure of entanglement then an
in-falling observer is going to get
cooked when he hits the horizon because
there's going to be a big wall of you
know big wall of radiation there and
that's what we call the firewall
so uh hawking's calculation tells us
that these these pairs being created at
the horizon had to be essentially
maximally entangled um
but there's also this radiation coming
out of the black hole
and if you think about what's going on
there's you know there's a problem here
because these these pairs are maximally
entangled uh but one of them is falling
into the black hole
and so if you think about the
entanglement peo there's being a new
entanglement being created with every
particle which uh which escapes from the
black hole right because you have an
essentially pure maximally entangled
state so you you create an ebit of
entanglement and so for you know for
each particle that comes out you get
more entanglement uh and so the
entanglement or of the black hole with
the rest of the world is going to be
increasing monotonically
uh and that approximation
is good as long as the black hole is
large um
on the other hand if this black hole is
supposed to evaporate away uh and
disappear the entanglement entropy
between the black hole and the radiation
you know the rest of the world has to
actually go down at some point right
which means that this
you know these these these hawking modes
at some point at late time have to be
entangled with the early hawking
radiation
and that's a violation of the monogamy
of entanglement that people have been
talking about a lot uh in this quantum
complex in the boot camp that this this
hawking photon for late times by
hawking's calculation it has to be
maximally entangled with the in-falling
partner but in order for the
entanglement entropy to go down it also
has to be essentially maximally
entangled with early radiation
and so this is this is the this is the
problem uh that we see you know it's
again a it's a version of cloning if you
you know if you want to use the cloning
language we could say that a has to be
cloned in r somehow that the same
entanglement has to be present in both
places or in both systems
um
and this is this was this is essentially
the firewall problem right that in order
to again in order to have unitary
evaporation ultimately the correlations
with b have to appear in the hocking
radiation that's going to be
inconsistent with the hawking pairs and
vacuum at the horizon and so instead of
just you know uh some cutesy violation
of the no cloning principle which might
disturb people who really care about
quantum mechanics but nothing else the
manifestation of the cloning in this
case is that an infalling observer would
hit the other horizon which is supposed
to be a region of space time where
nothing special is happening well
will essentially be some
terrible violent place you cross the
horizon you get bathed in radiation
maybe that's the end of space time who
knows so that's the firewall problem uh
how do you act you know how do you
actually make sense of what's going on
here
uh
and
no one really knows you know there's no
there's no good resolution to this
problem um
but
in the same spirit as the you know the
earlier thought experiments you could
ask yeah you could say well wait a
second uh part of this discussion was
not operational right we we just kind of
we divided the system into a b and r
sort of assuming this was a sensible
decomposition into subsystems um
but we never really verified that you
could
that you could detect the entanglement
in the radiation and then jump into the
black hole
right
uh and so you you could ask the question
well how hard is it to actually detect
that radiation detect the entanglement
between b and r by performing some
appropriate measurements on the
radiation
um and in this paper with daniel harlow
about a year ago
uh we decided to formulate that as a as
a question from the computational
complexity point of view
and you can uh and the way that we
argued it you know we applied some
different arguments but essentially the
task of decoding the radiation which is
a form of quantum error correction uh
in in the generic case uh is a problem
which is hard for the quantum complexity
class quantum statistical zero knowledge
uh and if you believe that you shouldn't
be able to you know solve problems in
quantum statistical zero knowledge in
quantum polynomial time uh
then that's actually a problem for
the
in principle feasibility of this
experiment uh because the black hole say
for a short shield black hole is going
to evaporate in an amount of uh
in
an amount of time which is roughly the
number of qubits in the black hole to
the three halves power
and so if it takes you exponential time
to actually perform the decoding by the
time you've done your decoding the black
hole is actually evaporate and there's
nothing to check uh and that was the
spirit you know we
elaborated on this uh you know you know
some 60 pages and you know many
different variations but that was
generally the idea that
it's possible you know this is what we
were proposing although i myself am not
necessarily convinced that it's uh it's
a good resolution uh that
that there's a computational complexity
obstruction to performing this
experiment and it's
uh
so it's an in principle obstruction and
this is what i'm saying at the be at the
beginning
but is it sufficiently
important in principle obstruction that
we should actually take it as a an
indication that it might be telling us
something about the structure of the
hilbert space
uh i don't know um i sort of interpret
it more
in the in the sense that if you don't
like this idea of firewalls maybe this
gives you a better way to sleep at night
but ultimately people need a theory
um
i unfortunately don't have time to get
into it uh scott aronson this year
came up with a strengthening of our
result uh in the sense that he was able
to base the hardness on a
yeah i guess a more widely believed
computational assumption so under the
under the assumption that there exists
an injective one-way uh one-way function
that is a one-way function for quantum
computers not just for classical
computers then again you can actually
turn that
into
well
if you could actually perform the kind
of decoding required to extract the uh
to verify the entanglement you could use
that to invert the one-way function
so i won't go into the argument but if
you're interested i can tell you about
it
um
and i unfortunately don't have too much
time i don't have time to tell you about
this i don't think am i out
yeah okay so
another possible resolution um to this
problem
uh is actually to think about a via or a
modification of quantum mechanics uh in
which
the singularity actually comes back into
play and all i'll say to you is that you
know we haven't discussed the
singularity yet but a not crazy idea is
that a singularity actually requires
that you impose a boundary condition and
a boundary condition would manifest
itself you know to us quantum
computation people as essentially post
selection and in a post-selected quantum
mechanics you can violate monogamy and
you can do all kinds of strange things
uh and so preschool and lloyd in
particular but also raphael busso who
was here a bit earlier i have thought
about the implications of this that
doesn't resolve all the problems but it
might be part of the part of the story
so that was the
the quick uh the quick tour that i
wanted to give you um
then i really think that
we can learn something about
about these basics basic physics
questions by uh viewing them through the
lens of quantum information certainly
the information theory has something
interesting to say and there are a host
of very interesting results these days
in high energy physics in holography in
which entanglement is playing a crucial
role in understanding the relationship
uh
you know say the the structure of space
and time um
whether computational complexity comes
in in some fundamental fundamental way
like i've been
suggesting i'm a little bit more
skeptical but the possibility is out
there
and so
now with that i will thank you for your
attention and i will release you to your
your dinners
maybe there's a few questions before
dinner
so they're hacking radiation photons are
they maximally entangled in how they
create their degrees of freedom or it's
just polarization
no it's also momentum
so they're yeah
yeah properly formulated it's in all
degrees of freedom
uh so i didn't get into that um
so part of the
i mean you could look at this amps
thought experiment and just say okay
well people are arguing about you know
they're they're working at you in this
kind of poorly defined semi-classical
regime and you know thinking about these
thought experiments but they don't
really have a good theory for analyzing
them and they get themselves confused so
what's the big deal um that's i think
something that's come out of it is that
whereas previously i think there was a
lot you know a fairly
i don't work in this area so you
probably know more than i do but um
there was a fairly widespread belief
that adscft told you not just about the
exterior region but could also be used
to probe the interior of the black hole
and
this kind of thought experiment which is
really telling you know illustrating to
us that we really know nothing about
what's happening in the interior of the
black hole uh sort of
caused people to reevaluate how much you
can learn from ads cft um
so
can you yeah i mean i think that there
are
uh
there's yeah so there are definitely
things to be learned by thinking of this
in the ads cft picture like in
particular one of the very simple
observations you can make uh is that if
you think about uh
the ads black hole with two asymptotic
regions um and you think about someone
falling in from region one and you ask
the question is there a firewall there
you know is he gonna uh and it is
obvious in that context that it depends
on what's happening on the other side
because someone on the other side could
send in some terrible
shock wave that's going to hit him right
as he crosses the horizon you can't know
that uh unless you actually have the the
rest of the description um and so
um
yeah i mean
it has it has served as a guide for
reasoning about these things and you can
construct kind of analogous uh analogous
questions
yeah
if uh
if there is a battery condition at the
at the singularity like in this post
selection scenario does that mean that
outside the horizon um
post bqp
no that's that's a good question so
um
it could um
but it probably doesn't um
so in order to you know
for in this scenario one of you one of
the things that you want to have happen
uh is that uh the post selection induces
a unitary transformation from the point
of view of somebody outside right and so
then the boundary condition so here we
have some in-falling matter and here we
have the you know info in falling
hocking photon outgoing hawking photon
that the state has to be at the form
maximally entangled between m uh and in
right and if it's not then the
transformation on the out degrees of
freedom is induced is not unitary um
so
if the transformation is unitary
then what you get is just bqp
right but if the transformation is not
unitary then it's no longer norm
preserving and the ultimate uh evolution
is going to be nonlinear once you
renormalize
and you open up the possibility of
uh of doing all kinds of crazy things um
and this is a this is a problem with the
proposal because in order for this to
work it kind of looks like you have to
prevent the unfalling matter and the
informing radiation from interacting
with each other
um
so
uh in a paper way back in 2006 lloyd
thought about this like the proposal was
originally by horowitz and maldocena
and then i guess preschool and
goddessman pointed out this issue that
you didn't get
that the induced transformation was not
unitary
if you had these interactions and then
lloyd pointed out that well if you
average over all possible interactions
then the
induced transformation might not be
unitary but it's deviations from unitary
are going to be very very small
and
you can see that as maybe a bug or a
feature i don't know but it'd be very
hard to exploit
such deviations for the purposes of you
know
solving pp hard problems
more questions
this time